[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i wore my good shirt for you i love it
absolutely look at you straight out of
[ __ ] andrew schulze's closet
i have autism yeah i said earlier i'm
like is brendan schaub having an estate
sale since he was
he was brutally murdered last week
um
he's a huge fan of bobby lee he should
be on this podcast i love bobby i saw he
was on your show yeah is i is by the way
bobby lee has been invited to my podcast
multiple times okay multiple times well
you should you should get them on i'm
gonna have to reach out to him yeah i
feel like he's so i might have to fly to
la and hold his hand and drag him on a
phone i think he just needs a real
invitation he knows i love him i cry
because there's been a lot of drama
lately and one of the things that
happened was somehow i know that my name
got entered into this thing and i don't
want to get into it in too much detail
but i'm like okay i must call bobby and
i called him and i said listen i don't
know what kind of i'm just hearing about
this nonsense now but i love you i would
never let anybody talk bad about you i
would never let anybody come on my show
and talk bad about you i think you're an
awesome guy i think you're incredibly
talented and i know that you have fear
of like performing and putting out a
special and stuff like that but i really
think you should because i think you're
one of the best comedians alive and i
think and i've said that to him many
many times you could tell there's
divisions
right so when this whole thing went down
you know my my phone i got texts from
allies
right and then
but then like the ones that didn't
attack you could tell like there was a
division can you say who the allies are
or no no no because if i tell you the
[ __ ] allies you're going to just
deduce and go all those no no no you
could because it's not like
i have a lot more allies than never call
because they know that i'm uncomfortable
and yeah they're so i could tell you
there was one ally that i heard that was
just a funny call that was okay so i'll
tell you who did call
this is how i am the funniest funniest
phone call was it right after age three
it was hilarious i'm calling to threaten
you is what he said oh yeah it was
sagura
the girl immediately after
he threatened me i'm calling to threaten
you
and i'm like come on man you know i mean
and he asked me how i was so sagura um
that's it maybe he called brendan and
said the same stevo
but maybe he called brandon and said the
same this whole l.a podcast scene is
does seem a little bit uh dead it's gay
they're all gay
they're all gay
they're
you know i might even and i won't even
name specific names but yeah the whole
drama that's going on in the l.a podcast
scene
it's one of the gayest things i've ever
seen this is like high school level
drama where they're like calling each
other and they're talking [ __ ] and
they're threatening each other and it's
like guys in new york the drama is
everywhere you can't afford your rent
yeah so it's actually real drama like
the new york podcast scene is somebody
being like i am homeless it's it's a
weird thing yeah it's a weird thing how
everyone is so poor in new york this is
people in manchester talking [ __ ] about
each other in new york the drama is like
my parents just kicked me off my family
plan and i'm 38.
i'm 38 and i don't have a phone
my roommate moved out i was not able to
secure another roommate for that room
this month
i'm actually going to kill myself
new york dramas like people hang
themselves people try to kill themselves
yeah these girls are smart enough to
know
exactly what you talked about which was
that there was a giant community that
didn't like shop and you could get them
to love your [ __ ] show by getting in
the mix of it
okay
yeah and annie letterman is super funny
but walk me to my car so i could suck
her dick is literally nothing it is it
is nothing nothing happened and i love
her to pieces but it's like when clyde
is like it's just girl jokes girls talk
it's not
you if it was you wouldn't be here what
should have happened in my humble
opinion
is that kalyan should have gone dude it
was a joke and it's gone too far and i'm
sorry that's how it should have ended
that's how it should have ended
shav is either too nice or
too slow
to be in he went to that bobby lee
podcast with kalila with he went to a
gunfight with a spork
okay dude she
i mean she was like an attorney the way
she
walked through that not everything she
said was accurate
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter but
it wasn't accurate she shredded him uh
honestly i'm just gonna tell everybody
something about this 300 pages
okay i've talked to a bunch of people
all i'm gonna tell you what you're
talking about though it's it's so
there's 300 pages of evidence is that
and they've discussed it that a bunch of
the stuff on the subreddit of tim of the
firing kid came from an ip address well
you're saying i p addresses but all that
i've seen shaub mention is that they
that it was linked to somebody with an
email that was a at tiger belly doc
whatever their url is their domain
that's all he said on the record i
thought it was talked about an ip dress
i've heard maybe maybe maybe i'm wrong
too which is fine because he kept asking
them during that podcast
is it possible for someone to create a
reddit account with an email address
at tigerbelly.com without here's all
must say about the 300 pages based on
people i've talked to yeah
the the people
that found the 300 pages what are the
pages why is it 300 pages is it just
that account and everything they posted
do you think and like yeah okay i i got
i haven't looked at the 300 pages
i'm just telling you what i've heard
it's just like clinton documents or
something but listen to me
what i've been told is that the people
who got these documents do not like
being called a liar
okay
which makes me think that people think
there's rules of this [ __ ] and that
people are following rules and that's
all i must say about it i don't what do
you mean by that that's all i gotta say
about it it doesn't sound like they uh
okay yeah i i i i wonder how many rules
and then there's people work outside the
rules that's what i'm trying to say and
this is based on just energy bro
that part is just energy but i almost
say is i love bobby lee i have number of
respect for kala annie letterman is my
friend i
this needs to stop they keep doing shows
on it
right i mean they did another show on it
and it's just have they done another one
now really yeah that's so funny it's
just like
you're doing mondo numbers i'm sure
that's what it's and this is my problem
he's like this is where
comedy's going it's becoming reality
show it's a reality show right these
reality stars would do crazy [ __ ] so tmz
would [ __ ] do a story on them and
that's where it's going and you know
where that all started chelsea lately
you on [ __ ] hgh what's going on here
you got that [ __ ] ufc fighter energy
seemed genuinely angry when you got
paranoid
you seem like a weird guy to smoke weed
with
i would be frightened
yeah you make bread and chub look pretty
damn good
[ __ ] yeah we talk about it every time he
comes in we make plans and i bet you
money the next time you come here it'll
be a year from now and i've still not
been met your family
and they're going to double down on the
who's that
who that who die who that
it's not funny man it hurts my feelings
i
i will make sure that happens it's not
gonna happen is it it's gonna happen
yeah it'll definitely is it because i
don't drink no no no no no one else
drinks in my family
we can't i can't come over and do a pool
thing yeah no we'll do how about fourth
of july we'll have a big fourth of july
party you will you you can you have one
girls yeah i will yeah well i'm home
fourth of july right
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you don't i'm
telling you right now
we're going to have a we're going to
have a brendan shop situation
if you don't invite me to this don't
edit that out
that's the worst thing i could say to
somebody right that is the worst thing i
can say we could have a shop all right
all right so be [ __ ] careful dude my
daughter's love bread
and you're [ __ ] kidding me right now
dude who dat who doesn't do that you're
[ __ ] kidding me right now dude
oh god oh [ __ ] oh my god he just shows
up with really expensive cars
i did not know what was going on with
brian callan and and
bobby lee and all these guys i had no
idea guys honest to god for all you guys
that wrote me little [ __ ] side notes
that brendan was a [ __ ] worm and all
this
because me and john bernthal were
talking about him listen guys
i i don't know what's going on i don't
know who it's on who
i don't know what's said up there
anymore like i said
before we even start this conversation
mental health is [ __ ] king so
i don't know what happened i really
might kind of tell me i know that after
i did the podcast
with
john i thought everything was fine there
was no [ __ ] you know and all of a
sudden two days later people like joey i
think you're wrong about brendan he's a
[ __ ] chooch he's this he's that and i
was like hey guys listen
i know the dude he's a student of comedy
he works hard
i i have not it's like i haven't been
around brendan for 18 months
but when you open up the computer
you see you know when you go on youtube
to get music or whatever there's always
a one
brendan this brendan special truly poppy
brendan this i said i don't even know
what i can say anymore i don't even know
you know i watch the special it's on
youtube
i watch like 15 minutes of it it's
brendan
is it [ __ ] hysterical
yeah no
but it's funny
he has some great [ __ ] things it's
like any other special i can watch on
netflix or any other [ __ ] thing i
mean okay it's outstanding to [ __ ]
like rodney and all those mothers
there's no
but brendan's doing okay he's trying
like i said i don't know what's going on
i'm hitting on bobby lee's girlfriend
bob lee's girl i don't know any about
that thing all i know is what his
character shows me when i open up he
started thick boy he does a food diary
he started a clothing line he's [ __ ]
trying if you don't like him don't pay
don't buy the shirts i've been on steve
lee's podcast a number of times you know
they're my friends andrew santino he's
one of my best friends both bobby and
andrew are coming to my wedding along
with steve
um you know they're my friends as you
know now i also i am a regular on king
and the sting and now the wing king's
thing and wing but i was a regular on
the show i've been on fire in a kid a
few times i've i've built a friendship
with brendan schaub brendan is also you
know i consider brendan a friend i mean
we're not as close as i am with the
other people but you know it just takes
time you know i had a very i wouldn't
say i had a contentious relationship
with brendan at first but you know it it
started off with me being like who the
hell is this ufc fighter thinking he
could be a comic you know i've come
since to change my tune about that
because it obviously doesn't matter what
people think about someone's art if you
think someone's funny or not it doesn't
even matter that's not what sells
tickets whatever brendan's got his work
ethic whatever people like about him it
works he's on like five six seven shows
he's built a thick boy network he's got
two specials whether you like him or not
whether you think he's funny or not it
doesn't matter people love to hate him
people love to love him and they go see
him he sells out places you know what
i'm saying i'm still trying to get
people to come watch me i'm a great
comic you hear what i'm saying listen to
me i'm a great comic okay you gonna have
a good time when you come to my show i
just gotta convince people to come to my
show so whatever he's got he convinces
people to come to his show so whether
you like him or not i don't really care
he's changed my whole feeling about that
it don't matter what people think about
someone they don't matter if they're
funny or not all that matters is if
people come watch them that's all that
matters um in terms of business you know
what i'm saying but i have a real
problem with the words i'm getting
bullied and traumatizing and i
understand he had a crazy child he said
on h3 right yes
you're 50 dude
okay you're 50 years old you're a
multi-millionaire you have successful
movies successful television shows and
you have a smoke show girlfriend
wife ah fiance whatever it is at this
time okay
you
that's not bullying okay yeah it's not
bull and listen you can easily say
what's happening to me in my instagrams
and my dms
is bullying
and i won't call it that it's just [ __ ]
talking people are [ __ ] docking me and
that's fine they're coming out it's fine
i have an army of care bears coming at
me what would you call what bobby got
though what would you call that
confrontation i don't really feel bad
for people that are [ __ ] millionaires
made fun of online i don't feel bad for
you that's right you that's that's your
[ __ ] biggest problem i feel bad is
that people on reddit are saying mean
words are you out of your [ __ ] mind
you're a millionaire right and you care
about what somebody on reddit says there
are people that you cannot eat yeah
there are people that don't have the
money to pay their rent they cannot get
their kids insulin
right i
am not privy to this drama
other than
it's spilling over into my world
so i didn't know what was going on i
didn't know that we don't talk
i don't i didn't know what was happening
all right i didn't know what was
happening
and then all of a sudden i'm getting hit
up like
you know so whatever happened between
bobby
kalila and brendan however they whatever
happened whatever happened on trash
tuesday whatever happened between annie
who all these people i don't know
it had nothing to do with me
it has nothing to do with me and
honestly i don't care
so however and i don't appreciate that
the fact that the [ __ ] is public that
they're dealing with it the way they're
dealing with it and making money at in
the process of doing it so
it just so it's like it's all for
content you know so and so then it all
it just riles up all the fans who think
they're a part of it you people think
you're a part of it these people don't
care about you or your opinion
so you have your own opinion and then
you're coming at me
bullying me
y'all like people are keep coming on my
game stream they're coming on my chat
they're coming on my instagram like yo
where do you stand on this as if it
matters what you think let me just say
something right right because i'm not
going to name who said this there's
three guys that said this on through
texas i'm going to show you i can show
you right i'm not going to say who they
are okay but they said
we're team bobby
okay
now if they had texted me we're team
bobby and then also tested brendan we're
team brendon texas we're also team bobby
to brandon yeah but if they did brendan
right
then that's a piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
you